Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Heute sprechen wir mit Christian Straßburger. Er kommentiert die EM mal bei Magenta TV. Und das interessiert mich. Darüber will ich heute sprechen in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 164. Christian, herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk.
Herzlichen Dank mit Liveband Helmut, Zerlet und Band haben wir gerade gespielt. Ist mir eine große Ehre, 164. Das heißt, du hattest bislang schon 163 Gäste oder?
Plus X, ja, manchmal waren es mehr. Aber halt nur im Kurzpass-Format.
Ja, im Kurzpass-Format. Und die waren alle bei dir auch hier in deiner Villa in München?
Nein, ich hoffe es, dass du das wertzuschätzen weißt. Nein, das ist natürlich jetzt das Besondere. Auch für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die hören wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Autoverkehr, vielleicht auch mal Vogelgezwitscher. Wir sitzen Corona-konform auf meiner Terrasse. Das durften tatsächlich noch nicht viele.
Oh, das ist mir eine große Ehre. Ich freue mich. Und ich habe auch einen tollen Kaffee bekommen von dir in der Rasenfunk-Version in den Farben getrennt. In der Sache. Verein passt ja auch aktuell, ne?
Wunderbar. Ja, absolut. Also ich hoffe, du fühlst dich wohl. Ich finde es schön, dass du hier bist. Wir wollen sprechen über deinen Job. Dazu kann ich vielleicht noch kurz erzählen, dass wir uns ja kennen. Also ich habe dich kennengelernt als Tinnitus, weil ich neben dir kommentieren durfte als Rami Benzivaini, das 2 zu 1 gegen den FC Bayern geschossen hat, und du ja auch fürs Frohenradio, also für Borussia Mönchengladbach. Die Spiele kommentierst, so haben wir uns kennengelernt. Jetzt bist du hier bei der EM und kommentierst. Was ist denn dazwischen passiert?
Ja, das frage ich mich auch manchmal. Also erst mal damals, als du Co-Kommentator warst, da möchte ich mich für den Tinnitus entschuldigen, aber es war halt noch, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Leute das noch wissen, es war ja ausverkauft, das Stadion. 54.000 Fans gegen den FC Bayern und dann war es auch noch, glaube ich, neunzigste Spielminute, Rami Benzibaini gegen Manuel Neuer, den hat er versenkt, Gladbach hat gewonnen, das Stadion ist explodiert, ich mittendrin und du hast dann da auch gesessen und hast dir gedacht, schön, dass ich hier gewesen bin.
Es war super.
Ja, aber klar, darf man erzählen, dass du Bayern-Fan bist oder?
Jaja, klar, die Leute wissen es ja, ich war also nicht mehr so ein Bayern-Fan wie früher, zumindest sympathisant, sagen wir es mal so. Ja, ja, so ein bisschen. Ein bisschen. Wenn sie spielen, tatsächlich. Sobald das Spiel aufhört, bin ich inzwischen, glaube ich, manchmal das Gefühl, der größte Bayern-Kritiker, weil da gibt es einfach viel zu kritisieren.
Okay, das machst du dann in der nächsten Folge mit jemandem, der dir da helfen kann. Was dazwischen passiert ist, ich habe einfach weiter gearbeitet, so wie das am besten sein sollte, nicht aufgegeben, versucht, Leistung zu bringen. Und dann, als sich die Telekom, Magenta, und die Produktionsfirma darum bemüht haben, die Rechte zu bekommen, da hieß es dann irgendwann vor ein paar Wochen, den Straßburger, den nehmen wir da mit. Dann gab es einen Anruf, und jetzt sitze ich hier, das ist natürlich für mich gerade das größte Berufliche meines Lebens.
Hier zu sitzen.
Hier zu sitzen, dann darf ich im Rasenfunk dann auch noch sein. Ich erlebe wunderbare Kollegen und Kolleginnen, mit denen ich da bislang tolle zwei Wochen habe. Ich habe fast jeden Tag das Glück, Johannes B. Kerner bei der Arbeit zu sehen. Das ist nicht so jetzt Lu Pudeleider, das ist wirklich ernst gemeint, weil das ist echt ein anderes Regal. Da habe ich noch nicht gefischt.
Woran merkt man das denn?
Er ist total routiniert. Man merkt einfach, dass er alles schon erlebt hat. Viele wissen das ja gar nicht, er hat damals sogar Fußball kommentiert für das ZDF. Dort habe ich ihn dann das erste Mal wahrgenommen und damals hat mir das schon gefallen. Er hat das Sportstudio moderiert und hat die Champions League für Sat.1 gemacht und nebenbei natürlich noch acht Millionen Samstagabendshows. Und dann ist das so eine gewisse Art und Weise, die er hat, die er mitbringt. Er sagt dann auch mal nicht, komm, das habt ihr mir jetzt hier aufgeschrieben, das machen wir, sondern er hinterfragt das, bringt seine Expertise rein, seine Erfahrungen und dann wird das anders gemacht und jeder fragt sich, warum haben wir das nicht gleich so gemacht. Das ist etwas, das ist mir bislang noch nicht über den Weg gelaufen, also so intensiv und alleine diese Sache, die hilft mir glaube ich für die Zukunft enorm.
Cool. Aber dann noch kurz, um die Lücke zu schließen, nicht, dass jetzt die Hörerinnen und Hörer glauben, du seihst vom Fohlenradio direkt zur EM gekommen. Du hast natürlich auch dritte Liga nebenher kommentiert, also sprich, das Kommentieren ist dein Lohn und Brot. War denn das jemals ein Thema, dass du auf der einen Seite für einen Verein tätig bist und auf der anderen Seite dann eben in der dritten Liga auch andere Mannschaften kommentierst?
Ja, es ist, Gott sei Dank, sage ich mal, Bundesliga und dritte Liga, das ist jetzt nichts, was sich irgendwie, das schneidet sich nicht oder überschneidet sich nicht. Ich habe bei Borussia Mönchengladbach, als ich vor viereinhalb Jahren angefangen habe, diese große Chance bekommen, im Radio sozusagen, Fohlenradio, die Spiele oder auch im FohlenTV, die Spiele live zu übertragen und hätte ich das nicht gemacht, hätte es damals niemand gegeben, der das gehört hat oder hätte, um dann zu sagen, hör mal, der kann doch auch dritte Liga machen für Magenta Sport.
Also das war quasi der Einstieg?
Genau, das war der Einstieg. Und dann lief das Parallel sehr gut, aber irgendwann wird es natürlich anstrengend. Ich war ja zusätzlich noch Social Media Manager, bin es auch noch, habe aber natürlich der ein oder andere, der Gladbach-Fan ist, der weiß das. Diejenigen, die mich jetzt zum ersten Mal hören, ich höre auf bei Borussia Mönchengladbach, ich bin bis Ende August noch dort, dann ist aber Schluss. Weil das alles unter einen Hut zu bekommen, das geht nicht mehr. Und ein bisschen mehr Konzentration brauche ich dann auch in den nächsten Wochen, Monaten und Jahren. Es kommen ein paar Dinge dazu. Darüber darf ich jetzt nicht alles sprechen, das ist die Medienwelt, die ich auch kennengelernt habe. Aber sobald ich da was zu sagen darf, dann werde ich dich natürlich anrufen. Aber so wie es läuft oder so wie es gelaufen ist, das hätte ich mir auch nicht alles so erträumt.
Spannend. Wie läuft denn das dann? Also ich hatte ja selbst mal eine EM-Vorbereitung, die ich machen musste und das war tough, muss ich sagen. Mich auf diese 24 Mannschaften vorzubereiten, ich glaube, ich habe Pro-Mannschaft und ich habe mich ja dann schon beeilen müssen. Ich glaube, ich habe eine Dreiviertelstunde bis Stunde pro Team gebraucht, das heißt, kann man sich hochrechnen, in die EM-Vorschau sind irgendwie 30 Stunden Vorbereitung geflossen und dann rede ich ja trotzdem nur so kurz über ein Team. Ich muss ja dann gar nicht viele Stammdaten zu Spielern, zum Beispiel, recherchieren, die ich brauche, für den Fall, dass ein Spiel mal dahin plätschert. Wie sah denn deine EM-Vorbereitung dann aus?
Die ganze rechte Geschichte, die war ja sowieso sehr kurzfristig. Also, dass Magenta TV das macht, das war ja nicht irgendwie ein halbes Jahr stand das fest, sondern das war kurzfristig. Dass Christian Straßburger das macht, das war noch kurzfristiger. Und als ich dann wusste, dass ich es mache, wusste ich aber auch noch nicht, was mache ich denn? Das hat auch noch mal ein, zwei Wochen gedauert. Und als das dann feststand, ich mache neun Spiele bei der Europameisterschaft, das sind die Teams, dann ging es natürlich intensiv rein. Ich gebe ganz ehrlich zu, dass ich jetzt nicht Dänemark oder Russland so oft 90 Minuten gesehen habe vor dieser Europameisterschaft, ich wüsste auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ob das alles irgendwo in Deutschland übertragen wird. Das hätte ich mir wahrscheinlich irgendwo im Next-Ziel müssen.
Also es gibt dann einen anderen Streaming-Ambieter, ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, ob ich einen Namen nenne. Ich bin voll in der Magenta-Falle schon, auf der Saunen gab es immer in der Nations League konnte man ganz gut so mal. Also da habe ich auch tatsächlich mal Nordmazedonien schon gesehen, einfach weil ich es witzig fand.
Die habe ich natürlich gegen Deutschland angeguckt. Aber ich habe mich echt darauf fokussiert, die Mannschaften zu machen, die ich übertrage. Ich war zum Beispiel bei den Deutschen nur so irgendwie drin, wie ich halt als Fan drin bin. Musste mich aber so in Dänemark, in Russland etc. einlesen, dann hatte ich das große Glück, dass irgendwann Spielverlagerung, die ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst.
Die haben mir auch den Hintern gerettet bei der EM-Vorschau. Ich war so froh, ich habe Tobi fast täglich genervt, Tobi, wann kommt endlich eure Vorschau raus? Ich brauche die. Ich brauche noch mal diesen taktischen Blick. Das kriegst du nirgendwo sonst.
Ich hätte es echt toll gefunden, wenn die das irgendwie auch als Heft rausgebracht hätten. Weiß aber natürlich, wie teuer das ist und war wirklich überrascht. Die haben, glaube ich, sieben Euro genommen.
Ja, das ist viel zu wenig.
Ich dachte, ich zahle 25 oder so und die hätte ich auch gezahlt, weil das hätte es auch verdient. Dieses EM-Magazin, das habe ich durchgelesen, auch Mannschaften, die ich nicht betreue, weil ich mir gedacht habe, was passiert denn da? Ich habe herausgefunden, wie Delaney sich aus dem Mittelfeld nach links fallen lässt, um dann den Spielaufbau nach vorne zu betreiben und so was. Ganz ehrlich, da fehlt mir jegliches. Ich habe keinen Trainerschein oder sonst irgendwas. Ich hätte wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal angemerkt, da kommt aber häufig über links, der Delaney. Jetzt weiß ich aber, warum. Das gehen wir durch die Mannschaften durch. Das hat mir extrem viel gebracht. Dann natürlich dieses Klinkenputzen bei transfermarkt.de, bei diesen ganzen Portalen. Dann haben wir das Glück, dass wir mit Deltatre, das ist für die Leute zu Hause, wie Opta, so eine Datenfirma, die wirklich tolle Jungs und Mädels hat, die da einiges zusammen schreiben, wo du dir denkst, woher wissen die das? Und dann hast du immer pro Spiel oder pro Team so eine Mappe und dann holst du dir da auch alles raus. Und dann steht dann vor dir so ein Tisch und dann liegen da auf einmal Millionen von Blättern und du denkst dir so, wie kriege ich das denn jetzt alles zusammen, ohne die Leute zu Hause auch noch zu nerven? Weil meine Art und Weise des Kommentieren, da reden wir sicherlich gleich auch nochmal drüber, du hast ja auch ein, zwei Spiele geguckt, ist halt die, ich möchte das Fußballspiel sehen, ich möchte es auch mit den Leuten zu Hause genießen, ich möchte nur auch das nach außen tragen, was ich auch selber weiß und verstehe, ich möchte authentisch sein. Wenn ich dann anfange, so Taktiken auseinander zu klamüsern, dann wäre ich nicht bei mir, das kann ich einfach nicht. Ich kann es nicht, Punkt, von mir kriegt man was anderes. So und das ist so ein bisschen ein grober Überblick.
Wie lange hast du so grob gebraucht, dich dann auf deine neuen Spiele vorzubereiten? Also komplett bist du ja noch nicht durch.
Ich bin noch nicht durch. Ich bin jetzt beim Achtelfinal, es gehen die Leute zu Hause, es ist ja auch vielleicht schön, Frankreich gegen Schweiz mache ich, Sensation, mit Martin Stranzl als Co-Kommentator.
Die Co-Kommentatoren bei Magenta, da müssen wir gleich noch drüber reden.
Da können wir auch drüber reden, da freue ich mich brutal drauf. Und das sind dann immer vier Tage pro Mannschaft. Vier Tage, wo ich dann auch mal, weil das kann ich nicht, ich mache mal eine Stunde und dann lasse ich es liegen, weil sonst werde ich verrückt. Das war schon in der Schule so.
Das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen. Die EM-Vorschau wurde auch, glaube ich, an vier, fünf Tagen vorbereitet, weil irgendwann nach der vierten Stunde bist du dann einfach platt. Wie, ne, erst muss ich noch die praktische Frage stellen. Weil das, also ich kenne die ganzen Zettel, die da liegen, das machen ja auch ganz viele Kommmentatoren so. Es gibt Leute, die haben dann so eine Mappe und es gibt Leute, die haben ganz viele kleine Post-its und du musst ja live werden, du spielst ja auch noch Dinge aufschreiben, damit einem da nichts durchrutscht. Das ist ja manchmal gar nicht so triviale, dass man während man ein Spiel sieht und kommentiert auch noch Notizen machen muss und hin und wieder noch ein Regisseur drauf hat, der einem was sagt. Das vergessen glaube ich die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer. Es ist eigentlich gut, dass sie es nicht mitbekommen, aber das kommt ja alles noch mit dazu. Warum machst du nicht gewisse Dinge davon digital? Warum muss das eine Zettelwirtschaft sein?
Also da fragst du eigentlich, das ist die falsche Frage für mich, weil ich mache es digital. Warum habe ich die Zettelwirtschaft? Ja ja, pass auf, die Zettelwirtschaft habe ich bei der EM nur. Die habe ich nur bei der EM jetzt, weil ich natürlich Angst habe, dass mir das digitale abschmiert. Ich habe ein iPad, das habe ich mir gekauft, dieses große iPad und damit mache ich alles. Dritte Liga etc. Dort habe ich alles drauf, das nehme ich auch immer mit. Ich benutze auch nur das und die Zettel habe ich, falls das nicht funktioniert. Das Einzige, was ich mir jetzt gedacht habe, was am meisten Sinn macht, weil mit diesem ganzen Wischen und so weiter und so fort und ich habe bei der dritten Liga habe ich nicht so viele Fenster auf, wie jetzt bei der Europameisterschaft, habe zusätzlich noch einen Datendienst, der mir live aus dem Stadion sozusagen die Daten überspielt. Dafür habe ich noch ein MacBook da stehen. Das muss ich alles bedienen und ich bin auch einer, der gleichzeitig kommentiert und googelt, weil da auf einmal was passiert, was ich gar nicht weiß oder frage ich mich, was war das denn noch mal oder bei Dänemark-Heuberg hat den Turban auf. Ich weiß natürlich Dieter Hoeneß und so weiter und so fort. Ich denke mir aber, ich weiß es, ich weiß auch, welche Spiele es war, aber es kann auch sein, dass ich denke, ich weiß es, aber ich weiß es gar nicht. Deswegen erzähle ich davon, gebe das gleichzeitig einen Blick rüber, sehe das Datum, weiß alles gar richtig, DFB-Pokalfinale schießt mich tot. Und ich kann das Gott sei Dank so multi dazu sein. Und die Zettel, die werden dann glaube ich nach der Euro, werden auch wieder verschwinden, außer die Aufstellungen. Die Spieler, die werde ich mir jetzt immer ausdrucken, das werde ich immer mir legen, die Startelf etc., dann die, die eingewechselt werden, weil ich jetzt gemerkt habe, vor allen Dingen mit diesen fünf Auswechslungen, das ist brutal, das kriege ich so schnell nicht digital hin, da brauche ich einfach nur Zettel weg, Zettel hin, Bums aus.
Ja, spannend, siehste, das wusste ich zum Beispiel gar nicht, dass du ansonsten so digital unterwegs bist. Ich habe da schon mit einigen Kommentatoren drüber gesprochen, bei denen war da meistens auch so ein Teil der Gründe, also zum einen die Ausfallsicherheit von Papier und bei vielen, kennt man ehrlicherweise auch noch aus der Schule, wenn man sich Notizen macht, dann verinnert man es ja auch gleichzeitig. Aber ich habe mich eben halt immer gefragt, ich arbeite ja logischerweise für den Rasenfunk komplett digital und ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel für die EM, habe ich für jede Nation einen Notizzettel mit irgendwie ein paar DIN-A4-Seiten und für jedes Spiel und ich kopiere dann am Ende das Spiel auch immer noch eine Kurzzusammenfassung, schreibe ich in das Nationen-Dokument rein und die wichtigsten Beobachtungen aus dem Spiel rüber, weil dann habe ich immer alles beieinander. Die werden dann quasi immer länger und ich baue aber, ich muss dann quasi mich nicht nochmal neu einarbeiten bei Italien, sondern ich weiß einfach, ach, steht alles da drin, da kann ich einfach in der Sendung, kann ich dann auch mal schnell aufmachen. Das ist dann quasi mein internes Google. Und dann baut die Arbeit so ein bisschen aufeinander auf. Deswegen finde ich das spannend, dass du es anders machst. Dann lass mal jetzt dann zur EM kommen. Dein allererstes Spiel war gleich Finnland, Entschuldigung, ja doch Finnland in Dänemark. Also das Spiel, bei dem Christian Eriksen zusammengebrochen ist. Das stelle ich mir schwierig vor. Ich habe es leider die Partie von dir nicht gesehen. Habe aber mitbekommen, dass du es ähnlich gehandhabt hast, wie Belaredi und relativ früh, als man gesehen hat, in welcher Schwere dieser Vorfall hat, einfach nichts mehr gesagt hast. Du musst uns jetzt nicht auf deine Gefühlsreise mitnehmen, aber magst du mal kurz erklären, was da auch intern bei euch, wie habt ihr dann da eigentlich noch kommuniziert?
Ja, der Tag war sowieso emotional. Erstes Europameisterschaftsspiel, brutalen Rucksack auf dem Rücken gehabt, weil man weiß ja nicht, schafft man das Euro? Oder ist man vielleicht nur dritte Liga? Um es mal so grob zusammenzufassen. Und dann passiert diese Situation, und ich weiß noch, dass ich seine Augen sehe. Und anhand seiner Augen bin ich davon ausgegangen, da gab es wahrscheinlich so ein Kopfball-Duell oder so ein Zusammenstoß. Das war ja gar nicht direkt zu erkennen. Und deswegen hat er, ich meine, jetzt sagt man das so salopp, aber das sieht man ja auf den Fußballspielen, dass da dann einer liegt und mal kurz benommen ist. Dann wurde es aber ja schon ganz schnell hektisch, weil, ich glaube, Kehr ihm die Zunge rausgeholt hat, damit er sie nicht verschluckt. Und da wurde es dann schon heiß. Und als man dann sah, jetzt wird es richtig kritisch, da habe ich dann gesagt, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, Sie werden verstehen, dass ich da jetzt nichts mehr sage, sondern einfach nur hoffe und bete, weil dann die Reanimation ja schon losging. Dann habe ich nur gesagt, oh nein, bitte nicht. Ich habe mich ausgestöpselt, war alleine im Studio dort. Ich glaube, Tim Froberg war auf meinem Ohr und hat gesagt, Christian, kommt gleich jemand. Dann ist ein Kollege gekommen, der Ole, ganz schnell ins Studio gerannt. Das sind echt viele Meter. Und dann war er bei mir und dann haben wir uns das angeschaut. Und ich habe einfach nur gehofft, bitte, bitte, bitte stirb jetzt nicht. Diese ganze Geschichte, dass die UEFA da, das muss man wissen, die UEFA macht die Regie. Das ist nicht Magenta, das ist nicht ZDF, das ist die UEFA. Dass die das da alles mitgeschnitten hat. Ich konnte alles sehen, musste alles wie zu Hause auch miterleben, weil ich ja drauf gucken musste.
Hattest du noch mehr als nur den einen Bildschirm?
Ich hatte nur den einen Bildschirm.
Gott sei Dank will ich das mal wenig wissen, was da auf anderen Kameras passiert ist.
Das will ich auch nicht wissen. Das musste ich dann irgendwie alles mir anschauen und dann wurde Gott sei Dank irgendwann nach, ich weiß es gar nicht, vielleicht waren sechs Minuten weggeschaltet bzw. auf die totale. Ich habe mein Headset runtergenommen, dann kam mein Kollege Benny Zander und wir haben uns dann im Arm gelegen und dann musste ich wirklich kurz Tränen vergießen, weil der gesamte Tag war sowieso schon so erdrückend etwas. Ich konnte mich nicht freuen, sondern ich hätte mich danach gefreut. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es mir schwer macht, zu atmen. Es war nur das bedeutendste für mich bis dahin. Und dann diese Gemengelage, ich musste einmal die Gefühle rauslassen, weil auch natürlich sofort werden da private Geschichten mit reingenommen und so was. Das kennt man ja einfach von zu Hause. Und dann einmal durchatmen und dann haben wir uns darauf verständigt, ich gehe zurück ins Studio und werde wahrscheinlich gleich irgendwann sagen, dass das Spiel vorbei ist. Finito. Und dann kommt die Information, die spielen gleich wieder. Mein guter Freund Janik Bakic, den kenne ich seit zehn Jahren, ist auch Teil des Teams. Ich bin froh, dass er dann gekommen ist und war dann die ganze Zeit bei mir. Und dann habe ich unseren Projektleiter gefragt, ob er bitte kurz kommen kann. Und dann habe ich zu ihm gesagt, was soll ich jetzt machen? Guck mich an. Und dann hat er gesagt, du machst das, wie du es fühlst. Es war komplett meine Entscheidung, was mache ich jetzt? Und dann habe ich für mich entschieden, das ist jetzt kein normales Fußballspiel mehr. Da gibt es jetzt auch nichts Jubel, Trubel und ich brauche jetzt auch nichts von Zetteln abzulesen oder sonst irgendwas. Ich habe mich dazu entschieden, okay, wir haben das vorher alle gemeinsam erlebt. Jetzt machen wir das gemeinsam auch durch bis zum Ende. Habe dann mal fünf Minuten, bin ich mal ruhig gewesen, Yannick saß neben mir, um mir Informationen zu geben, was sagt der Verband, wie sieht es mit Eriksen aus? Und es wurde immer besser, immer positiver. In Kopp Magen haben die Leute gejubelt, ihm geht es gut, er hat sich gemeldet. Die Mannschaft von Dänemark hat man gemerkt, die will jetzt auch für Eriksen spielen und so was. Und nach, ich glaube, Minuten 60 konnte man zumindest nochmal normal dieses Ding zu Ende bringen. Das aber gespielt wurde und so weiter und so fort. Was da alles passiert ist, wie es passiert ist. Das ist natürlich lächerlich. Das weiß ich nicht. Ich hoffe, da gibt es ein Learning für die Zukunft.
Wie war denn da intern die Kommunikation? Habt ihr darüber diskutiert, ob ihr einfach rausgeht aus den UEFA-Bildern?
Das weiß ich nicht, da bin ich nicht dabei. Ich sitze nur im Studio. Und wenn jemand mit mir spricht, der Regisseur oder der Leiter der Sendung, dann kriege ich das aufs Ohr. Ich gehe mal davon aus, die haben sich alle sofort zusammengefunden. Aber wie dann was entschieden wurde, das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, wir haben nach sechs Minuten oder nach fünf eine Bauchbinde gezeigt. Und nach sechs sind wir raus.
Ja, genau. Ihr seid ungefähr zeitgleich mit dem ZDF rausgegangen. Es ist interessant, weil man von außen einen anderen Blick hat und der erste Impuls ist, dass man sich denkt, bitte schaltet doch einfach von diesen Bildern weg. Man könnte aber ja auch selber wegschalten und muss sich dann selber auch hinterfragen. Ich meine, klar, ich muss es gucken, weil ich muss ja irgendwie darüber berichten. Ich habe aber dann zum Beispiel, als das Spiel erst mal unterbrochen war, dafür entschieden, dass ich mich jetzt auch gar nicht mehr am Fernseher aufhalte. Der lief dann quasi gemutet weiter. Ich bin so alle paar Minuten vorbeigelaufen, um einfach zu sehen, wenn wieder irgendwie ein Sportkommentator oder ein Moderator zu sehen ist, dann mache ich wieder den Ton an, weil ich muss ja einfach nur wissen, wie es weitergeht. Aber deswegen finde ich das ebenso spannend, weil das von außen immer so einfach aussieht. Intern ist aber ja dann doch so eine Sondersituation zu sein, scheint, dass es dafür keine klaren Pläne gibt, was man jetzt macht. Weißt du, ob das jetzt dann für die Zukunft dann auch intern bei Magenta vielleicht irgendwas angestoßen hat?
Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass man jetzt alle Fernsehanstalten und sicherlich auch in vorderster Linie die UEFA auf so etwas vorbereitet ist, was hoffentlich nie wieder passiert. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das mit den Bildern etc., dass wir das nicht mehr erleben werden. Also oder?
Ehrlicherweise ist es die UEFA. Ich bin mir da, ich weiß nicht, ob du zufällig gesehen hast, was der Regisseur einer französischen Nachrichtenagentur, also der von der Weltregie gesagt hat. Der fand ja alles super, so wie er es gemacht hat. Aber da müssen wir jetzt auch nicht tief reingehen. Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht irgendwelche über Leute herziehen, die ich weder kenne, noch da die Hintergründe kenne. Das ist eh schon schwierig genug. Aber das war dein Auftakt in die EM. Wie lief es denn danach? Wie fällt jetzt so, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele deiner neuen Spiele hast du jetzt dann gemacht?
Sieben. Ich mache jetzt noch das Achtelfinale, Frankreich-Schweiz und dann ein Viertelfinale.
Wie fällt dein vorläufiges Fazit aus?
Wir haben ja gerade schon mal kurz gesprochen, bevor, wie sagt man, off the record, wo die wirklich interessanten Dinge besprochen werden, wo ich dir gesagt habe, wie fröhlich ich bin, dass viele Spiele echt attraktiv sind. Also die EM macht Spaß. Das würde ich jetzt mal so sagen. Ich hatte das große Glück, dass die Spiele, die ich gemacht habe, da bin ich jetzt nirgendwo rausgegangen und habe gesagt, das war jetzt aber nichts. Das kann auch daran liegen, dass ich jemand bin, der sich auch gerne begeistern lässt. Es ist ja alles toll. Wenn man das nur aufs Fußball runterbricht, auf 11 gegen 11, 90 Minuten, und du blendest alles das, was da an Irrungen und Wirrungen drumherum ist, wenn du das ausblendest, dann ist es doch genau das, warum wir hier sitzen, warum wir das alles mal wollten. Ich für mich habe nicht entschieden, das ist ja nichts, was du entscheiden kannst, also Gefühle kann man nicht entscheiden, aber ich fühle das, ich fühle einfach dieses 90 Minuten Fußballding. Da bin ich enthousiastisch, das macht mir Spaß. Ich gucke ja jetzt auch das 1000. Fußballspiel, aber es begeistert mich trotzdem, oder eben nicht. Ich lasse alles andere drumherum aus, dass mir einer aufs Ohr redet, dass ich da was habe. Dass hier noch eine Anweisung, pass auf, hier kommt Werbung. Und da musste das vielleicht noch verkaufen. Vielleicht kommt das ja irgendwann, wo ich dann nach 15 Minuten sagen muss, übrigens der Kampf des Jahrhunderts und so weiter und so fort. Wenn man das alles weglässt und das nur auf das Minimalste runterbricht, dann muss man sagen, es ist so wunderschön und es macht so viel Spaß. Und es geht so schnell vorbei und ich muss echt, wenn das alles vorbei ist, mache ich auch mal Urlaub, eine Woche, um die ganzen Eindrücke noch mal Revue passieren zu lassen. Weil das kennt man auch mittlerweile aus dieser Zeit. Es rast ja alles an einem vorbei. Die sieben Spiele, wenn du mich jetzt fragst, wie waren denn oder wie hießen denn die sieben Spiele, weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich dir das alles aufzählen könnte, weil es so schnell ist. Aber die Eindrücke, Michael Ballack, der unser Experte ist, mit dem dann in der Garderobe zu sitzen, 20 Minuten, und mit ihm über Fußball zu sprechen, beziehungsweise ihm dann irgendwann zu sagen, weil Michael Ballack mein Fußballheld ist er immer noch und bleibt er auch, weil er uns zehn Jahre echt aus der Scheiße gezogen hat ganz oft. Wir hatten ja wirklich nicht viele tolle Spieler und da gab es dann nur Ballack, Ballack, Ballack, Ballack. Und dann habe ich irgendwann zu ihm gesagt, ich wollte dir noch sagen, du bist mein Fußballheld. Dann hat er gelächelt, hat er gesagt, danke schön, das ist nett. Dann habe ich ihm erklärt, warum. Ich habe ihm dann gesagt, hör mal zu und wie du aus der Nationalmannschaft raus geäkelt wurdest, das ekelt mich heute noch an. Er hat mir zugestimmt, weil die Leute wissen das ja noch, wie das damals abgelaufen ist, solche Sachen mitzubekommen. Oder unsere Maskenbildnerin, die mich dann da immer schminkt vorher, die sagt dann so, wenn ich sie frage, ja wen hast du denn eigentlich schon mal so geschminkt? Ja, ich habe 15 Jahre Dalli Dalli gemacht mit Hans Rosenthal, da habe ich ja vom Stuhl gefallen, da habe ich alles gefragt, wie war das, wie war dies, wie ist das Fernsehen heute und so weiter und so fort. Das sind Dinge, die haben gar nichts mit Fernsehen und mit Fußball und mit Live zu tun, aber drumherum das alles, ich fühle mich wie so im Phantasialand. Das ist, jeden Tag stehe ich da in der Achterbahnschlange und weiß, gleich sitze ich da wieder und dann werde ich wieder durch den Looping gefahren und ich freue mich drauf.
Das merkt man auch deinen Kommentaren an. Und du hast es ja auch schon selber vor ein bisschen eingeordnet. Du bist nicht der Analytiker, sondern du bist derjenige, der quasi emotional kommentiert. Und vielleicht auch durch meine Arbeit an Elfleben, wo ich jetzt einfach sehr, sehr viele alte Fußballspiele mir angeguckt habe, ist mir das noch mal extrem aufgefallen, wie sehr sich das verändert hat. Hin von einem, früher war der Kommentator derjenige, der beschrieben hat, der quasi eine Stütze dabei war, wer gerade den Ball hat. Im Wesentlichen wurden die Namen genannt. Das wurde dann durch Privatfernsehen, Sat.1, RTL, Einstieg in die Fußballübertragung, wurde das dann schon wesentlich emotionaler. Aber dennoch hörst du auch einen krassen Unterschied, sogar wenn du es mit der WM 2006 vergleist, wo ja damals dann schon der Kommentar bei den deutschen Spielen sehr logischerweise, möchte man fast sagen, parteiisch war aber auch schon sehr emotional. Und trotzdem gab es noch viele Bilder, die einfach nur standen. Und so alte Granten des Kommentierens wie Marcel Reif oder Fritz von Turno Taxis, bei denen hast du noch richtig diese fast schon Methode, dass ein Tor fällt. Es wird kurz Tor, Führer und dann aber Ruhe bis zur ersten Zeitlupe. Und bei der ersten Zeitlupe, wirklich bei Fritz von Turno Taxis, kannst du die Uhr danach stellen. In der Sekunde, in der die erste Wiederholung kommt, dann fängt er wieder an zu sprechen. Vorher sagt er einfach gar nichts, außer er hat halt irgendwie gesagt, uiuiui, was macht er denn? Und dann aber Ruhe, Ruhe, Ruhe. Erste Zeitlupe kommt, dann fängt er an das Ganze zu kommentieren. Woher glaubst du denn, dass sich das verändert hat, dass heutzutage so viel emotionaler gesprochen wird?
Also so wie du es jetzt zusammenfasst, das ist jetzt nichts, worüber ich mir ständig Gedanken mache, wie war das früher, weil ich glaube, alles hat seine Zeit. Und ich glaube, es gibt auch noch viele Kollegen, die das vielleicht so machen. Die Frage ist ja, wer entscheidet denn, was gutes Kommentieren ist und was nicht, oder was ist richtig und was nicht. Man sitzt ja als Fan zu Hause, schaut sich dieses Spiel an, und der eine sagt, boah, wie der das macht, toll. Und der andere sagt, wie Max Jakob Ost sitzt man dann und sagt, meine Güte, warum, warum?
Nee, nee, so sitze ich nicht da. Ich finde, bei mir hängt es ganz krass vom Spiel ab. Es gibt Spiele, da stört mich das Emotionale, weil ich das Gefühl habe, es lenkt gerade ab. Ehrlicherweise sind das ganz oft Spiele von Deutschland, weil ich dann schon das Gefühl habe, da werden einfach viele Dinge nicht erklärt, die aber zu sehen sind. Also Beispiel Deutschland gegen Ungarn, Kimmich spielt in der zweiten Halbzeit eine völlig andere Positionierung. Was verändert das mit dem Spiel? Und es wird so in einem Nebensatz erwähnt. Aber auch später in der Analyse fehlt dann eigentlich auch der Platz dafür. Und in Deutschland wird das immer sehr klar getrennt, Analyse und Kommentare. Das ist auch okay, weil du kannst auch nicht von jedem Kommentator erwarten, dass er das eben einfach macht. Aber bei mir ist es ehrlicherweise, ich finde da, also ich kann auch sehr gut mit dem emotionalen Leben. Also zum Beispiel, du hast Dänemark gegen Russland kommentiert, das 4 zu 1. Da gab es ja dann sogar später den Mitschnitt, den Magenta TV veröffentlicht hat, wo man mal gesehen hat, wie sehr du eigentlich wackest auf deinem Drehstuhl, während du Tore kommentierst. Das fand ich super. Also was soll ich da dran schlecht finden, dass du da aus dem Sattel gehst, weil da gehe ich ja vor dem Fernseher auch aus dem Sattel. Aber es gibt auch manchmal Spiele und wirklich, ich kann da nicht vorher sagen, jetzt kommt schon die Kommentatorenpolizei und holt mich ab. Also das ist gar nicht so, ich finde nicht, dass es dann richtig unten falsch gibt. Ich nehme nur wahr, dass es sich verändert hat. Mich hätte es eben interessiert, was du da drüber denkst.
Ja, was soll ich da drüber denken? Also ich war ja auch nicht irgendwie, ich saß nicht in der Schule und hatte jeden Tag acht Stunden, so kommentierst du.
Ja, stimmt ja.
Sondern ich sitze, irgendwann hatte ich mal den Traum, das zu machen. Und habe dann angefangen, im Radio zu kommentieren, vor 50 Leuten bei Rot-Weiß-Oberhausen, dann irgendwann vor 10.000, vor 50.000 bei Borussia Mönchengladbach, dann irgendwann dritte Liga, Fernsehen ist nochmal was ganz anderes als Radio. Und dann wirst du da hingesetzt und dann wird gesagt, so jetzt kommentierst du dieses Spiel und dann kommentiere ich dieses Spiel.
Ja, genau.
Und dann mache ich das so, wie ich dieses Spiel kommentiere, als Zwölfjähriger und jetzt als 32-Jähriger. Und dann sagt mir danach jemand, das gefällt mir. Und der andere sagt mir, das gefällt mir nicht.
Wie gehst du damit um, dass du nie alle zufriedenstellen kannst?
Das war am Anfang brutal schwer. Weil mein, also ich sag's mal so, ich glaube jeder Mensch hätte gerne, dass zu einem gesagt wird, du bist gut, du gefällst mir. Wenn dann aber mal Leute kommen, und die kommen ja vor allen Dingen im Netz, krass mit Beleidigungen, dann musste ich erst mal schlucken. Aber das habe ich hinter mir. Ich bin 32, ich hab's hinter mir. Es ist total toll. Ich schreibe mit allen Leuten, wobei ich muss sagen, es wird jetzt immer mehr, das kann ich nicht mehr alles leisten, aber mit den meisten schreibe ich, setze mich auseinander, und wir kommen am Ende immer auf einen Nenner. Mit denen, die irgendwie, keine Ahnung, beleidigen oder sowas, mit denen spreche ich gar nicht mehr. Mit denen rede ich, das sehe ich gar nicht mehr. Und das ist ganz toll. Das habe ich alles, weil ganz ehrlich, wenn dich fremde Menschen verletzen können, dann stimmt was nicht. Irgendetwas musst du ändern. Das geht nicht. Weil, wo willst du dann hin? Dann musst du irgendwo anders hin. Dann musst du irgendwas anderes machen. Dann musst du gucken, wie kommst du zu dir?
Ja, aber sie verletzen dir was, wo du dein Herzblut reinlegst. Also ich sehe schon, da brauche ich von dir ein Coaching. Ich brauche das unbedingt. Bei mir 1000 positive Kommentare. Einer finde ich was schlecht. Und dann denke ich mir so, oh Gott, ja.
Ja, aber warum? Das nimmt das noch nicht.
Naja, weil es macht hier auch die Arbeit besser. Also die konstruktiven Kommentare sind der Grund, warum der Rasenfunk so ist, wie er ist und F-Leben ist, so wie es ist und dass das nicht einen gefällt. Das ist mir sogar völlig klar. Aber was ich tatsächlich nicht schaffe, ist bei konstruktiven Nörglereien, das sind ja die, die richtig weh tun, wenn jemand kritisiert und man merkt, Scheiße, der hat einen Punkt, Mist. Aber damit kann ich noch umgehen, weil da bin ich ja selber dran schuld. Und dann nehme ich mich einfach selber in die Pflicht. Aber tatsächlich dieses Gehate, was halt dann hin und wieder kommt, ich meine der Rasenfunk ist da noch weitgehend von verschont, aber je bekannter das wird, und ehrlicherweise auch mit 11 Leben, aber schon ein paar Leute bei mir aufgeschlagen, ich schaffe das noch nicht, das irgendwie so wegzuschieben und mir zu denken, ja du bist halt einfach nur ein Depp. Weil ich mir so denke, ey, ich stecke da so viel Liebe rein, wie kann man denn dann so gemein sein?
Das verstehe ich schon, was du sagst, und es ist ja nicht so, dass ich das nicht auch hatte. Aber du wirst ja sonst irgendwann bekloppt. Also ich sage auch immer den anderen Leuten, 23 Stunden strahlt die Sonne auf dich. Und du kannst dich dahin legen, und es ist so toll, und es ist so knackig schön, aber du redest mir am Ende die ganze Zeit nur über die eine Stunde, wo es geregnet hat. Das ist doch kein Leben. Das Leben ist doch das Beste, rauszuziehen, und natürlich daraus zu lernen, okay, ich muss vielleicht auch nochmal im Rucksack eine Regenjacke dabei haben, für den Fall. Aber nicht schon bei 35 Grad anziehen, weil es ja gleich regnen könnte. Das ist ja, was ist das? Da gehst du ja kaputt. Ich glaube einfach, dass wenn du dann auch mal Leute siehst im Netz, die 95 Prozent Lob bekommen, die antworten aber nur auf die 5 Prozent Negatives. Die sagen dann, du bist eh ein Trottel oder so, aber dass da mal steht, danke, danke für das nette Feedback oder sowas, das kommt gar nicht mehr. Weil jeder schaut nur noch, da ein Hater, hier ein Dings, hallo ihr Trolle, ja, ich weiß, ihr mögt mich sowieso nicht, aber trotzdem poste ich das und so. Das ist für mich eine Herangehensweise. Nur negativ, das bringt ja auch gar nichts. Aber irgendwann frisst man das glaube ich in sich rein. Und das muss raus, das muss weg. Das Leben ist schön. Es ist schön. Wir sind gesund. Du hast hier, wenn wir mal über uns sprechen, wir sitzen hier schön, wir trinken Kaffee. Wenn wir Hunger haben, essen wir was. Was ist denn los? Wir gehen an den Stadion, kommentieren Fußball. Ich darf bei der Europameisterschaft dabei sein. Das musst du doch genießen. Sonst sitzen wir irgendwann mit 80 Jahren und sagen uns, hätte ich das mal genossen. Und diese ganzen Negativitäten oder sowas, ich glaube, das kann man filtern, ohne überheblich oder arrogant zu wirken. Also es gibt ja auch wirklich Leute, die sagen, ja aber der beschäftigt sich jetzt nicht damit. Wie arrogant ist der denn? Das hat doch nichts mit Arroganz zu tun. Ich möchte einfach so wenig wie möglich negative Sachen in meinem Leben haben. Das kommt aus mir heraus, weil als ich klein war, als ich Kind war, war vieles schlecht. Da war vieles nicht einfach. Ich bin durch deutlich Schlimmeres durchgegangen, als durch eine Kommentarspalte bei Facebook oder sowas. Ich habe wirklich Herzschmerz gehabt für Dinge, die greifbar waren. Da nehme ich mir das nicht zu Herzen, sondern erfreue mich daran, dass der liebe Gott gesagt hat, weißt du was, damals war es scheiße, jetzt machen wir heute mal ein bisschen mehr Sonnenschein. Sonst wäre das, glaube ich, doch auch undankbar irgendwie.
Es gibt da nichts, was man dagegen sagen kann. Ich muss mehr wie Christian Straßburger sein. Mehr will ich dazu eigentlich gar nicht sagen. Glaubst du, dass Social Media auch die Art und Weise verändert hat, wie eben kommentieren funktioniert? Und zwar in zwei Richtungen. Die eine Richtung ist eben das, was wir gerade schon hatten, dass du immer einen direkten Rückkanal hast. Also früher gab es Leserbriefe oder Zuschauertelefon, aber das ist dann gar nicht alles bei dir angekommen. Jetzt schreibt dir sofort jemand bei Instagram entweder Straßi, du bist der Geiste oder du Huso, geh sonst wo hin.
Was hast du denn erlebt? Huso hat noch keiner geschrieben.
Dann machen wir einen Podcast über den FC Bayern, uns ist ein bisschen kritisch. Da geht es ab, das kann ich echt mal sagen. In der Sekunde ab der Kirchvertrag-Folge bei F.Leben wurde es bei mir interessant im Postfach. Na ja, weiß ich nicht, manchmal ein bisschen. Aber wenn es den Leuten Befriedigung gibt, also das ist die eine Richtung, und die andere Richtung ist ja aber auch, dass eben so etwas passiert, wie dass über soziale Netzwerke nochmal dein Torjubel von den vier Toren gezeigt wird. Und dass man das ja auch zwar in dem Moment nicht im Hinterkopf hat, aber du weißt ja auch quasi, es kann sein, dass irgendwann mal ein Best-of von dir erscheint oder deine lustigsten Sprüche werden irgendwann mal auf YouTube geklippt oder irgendwie sowas. Das wirkt ja auch auf die Kommentatorinnen und Kommentatoren ein. Glaubst du, das ist so das Wesentliche, was sich verändert hat?
Das kann sein. Ich glaube aber, dass es keinen gibt, ich kenne zumindest keinen, der für einen Best-of kommentiert. Das glaube ich nicht, das will ich nicht glauben, weil du kannst ja nicht mehr draus machen als das, was du da siehst. Also Dänemark, Russland, das ist ja einmal im Jahr oder sowas, oder vielleicht einmal in zwei Jahren. Oder ich hatte mal irgendwann Kaiserslautern, Preußen Münster, wo dann ein Freistoß reinfällt in 90 plus 3. Danach die 8 Spiele, war aber auch wieder nix. Ich glaube, wenn du authentisch bist, so wie du bist, oder sagen wir mal so, ich weiß, dass wahrscheinlich im Netz nicht irgendein Best-of von irgendwelchen Leuten zusammengeschnitten wird, hier das Best-of, wie er erklärt hat, dass die Mittelfeldspieler abkippen. Davon gehe ich mal aus. Sondern es wird dann halt rumgebrüllt, rumemotionalisiert, einer wippt auf dem Stuhl rum und sowas. Auch ein Learning. Ich wusste nicht, dass gefilmt wird. Wusste ich nicht. Wusste nicht, dass dann 90 Minuten gefilmt wird. Ich hatte nur Hose an. Das kommt teilweise vor, dass das dann nicht mehr ist. Nein, aber beim nächsten Spiel wusste ich dann, dass gefilmt wird. Aber es hat nichts verändert, weil es wieder vergisst. Ich glaube, dass die Kommentatoren und Kommentatorinnen sich viele Gedanken machen drum herum. Aber ich bin mir sicher, sobald dann das Ding losgeht, dann sind wir alle fokussiert. Dann geht es darum, schön das, was man vorbereitet hat, dann das Spiel wirken zu lassen und so weiter und so fort. Aber ja, es hat sich verändert, aber vielleicht hat das nichts mit uns zu tun als Kommentatoren, sondern eher mit dem ganzen Drumherum. Ich glaube, dass es auch, wenn Fritz von Turn und Taxi zum Beispiel jetzt noch kommentieren würde, was toll wäre, da würde es auch von ihm tolle Zusammenschnitte geben, jede Woche vielleicht. Aber der kommentiert trotzdem genauso wie vor 30 Jahren.
Das war übrigens ein interessantes Learning aus 11 Leben, dass ich auch Kommentatoren, wo ich früher, also ich war sowieso früher Kommentatoren kritischer, das ist aber je näher du dich mit dem Job beschäftigst, desto mehr Respekt hast du einfach vor der Arbeit. Das ist vielleicht auch ein Klassiker für so Medienberufe, die es gibt.
Was bedeutet denn Kommentatoren kritischer?
Ich war sehr oft genervt früher von Kommentatoren und das passiert mir heute nur noch bei welchen, wo ich einfach auch klar inhaltlich benennen kann, warum ich die nicht mag. Also bei mir hängt es dann natürlich dann schon auch mit der taktischen Analysefähigkeit an. Also wenn ich einfach jemanden schon dreizehnmal habe sagen hören, wenn ein Mittelfeldspieler ein Offensiver für einen Stürmer angewechselt wird, jetzt gehen sie es defensiver an, dabei verschieben sie halt auf eine Dreierkette und stürmen halt jetzt mit Dreien und nicht mehr mit Zweien, dann nervt mich das dann so sehr, dass ich dann in Zukunft immer einen negativen Bias habe, wenn ich denjenigen sehe. Das sind aber ganz wenige, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Und ich werde auch nie die Namen sagen, weil die können da ja über, die sollen einfach ihr Ding machen. Und das ist halt dann nicht meins. Genauso wie ja auch ganz viele Leute den Rasenfunk fürchterlich finden. Und dann sollen sie ihn halt bitte einfach nicht hören. Aber bitte schreibt mir nicht bei Instagram, wie schlecht er ist.
Aber besser wäre doch, wenn sie es nicht gut finden, aber trotzdem hören.
Nee, nee, nee, ich will ja keinem schlechte Laune machen. Nee, aber früher war der Kommentator für mich auch noch wichtiger. Vielleicht auch, weil ich mich anders damals mit Fußball beschäftigt habe. Und jetzt habe ich aber festgestellt mit der Arbeit an 11leben, wie großartig auch manche Kommentatoren waren, die ich früher manchmal nicht mochte. Also ich zum Beispiel Marcel Reif war immer für mich so ein Grenzfall, weil der oft so persönlich beleidigt war, wenn das Spiel schlecht war. Zumindest wirkt es auf mich so. Und heute, wenn ich mir jetzt dann aber die alten Spiele nochmal angucke, denke ich mir, wie gut das ist, dass er einfach sagt, dass man so halt in der Champions League auch nicht spielen kann. Und damals hat es mich halt genarrt, vielleicht auch, weil ich damals noch Fan war. Und jetzt eher Journalist. Oh, jetzt kommt das 12 Uhr, Leute. Jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Was ist hier los?
Ja, warte, da müssen wir ganz kurz, ganz kleine Pause. Liebe Hörer, gleich geht's weiter. Wir sind wieder zurück und sind jetzt gesegnet durch ein 12 Uhr Mittagsleuten, in das wir reingesendet haben. Ich war gerade dabei, den Punkt auszuführen, dass ich früher genervter war und das inzwischen aber wertschätzen kann, wenn jemand auch mal darauf hinweist, ein Spiel ist jetzt nicht gut oder eine Leistung ist nicht gut von einer Mannschaft. Da war ich früher als Fan häufiger beleidigt und weiß das inzwischen sehr zu schätzen. Da würde mich interessieren, was sind für dich die Kommentatoren, an denen du dich orientierst?
Aktuell, mittlerweile kenne ich ja viele.
Jetzt musst du alle nennen.
Was ist denn dein Vorbild? Das hat man früher und irgendwann dann nicht mehr. Weil man irgendwann aus diesem Konkon rausgeht und dann muss man selber als Schmetterling durch die Gegend fliegen. Aber ich fand natürlich Frank Buschmann und Wolf Fuss, die fand ich geil. Und die finde ich heute noch geil. Wolf Fuss ist jetzt auf einmal mein Kollege. Ein sehr guter Freund von mir hat mir ein Foto gemacht. Ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es beim letzten Spiel war. Da war dann das Studio. Vorne steht Johannes B. Kerner und Michael Ballack. Und hinten auf dem Screen waren wir zwei. Und das habe ich nachts im Bett eine Stunde gebraucht, um dann einzuschlafen, weil ich mir das angeschaut habe und dann habe ich rekapituliert, wie war das denn früher? Was hast du eigentlich gemacht? Wie ist das eigentlich alles entstanden? Und dann ist das so. Wie fühlt sich das denn jetzt an für dich, der Klassiker? Wie fühlen sie sich nach dieser Geschichte? Und es fühlt sich alles so unwirklich an, dass das dann alles so um dich passiert. Und du bist Teil und Johannes B. Kerner sagt, und jetzt viel Spaß mit ihrem Kommentator Christian Straßburger, da fange ich immer an zu lächeln, weil ich mir denke, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Und natürlich habe ich mich damals irgendwie gesagt, ich möchte mal dahin, wo die sind. Nicht gesagt, ich möchte mal so sein wie sie, sondern ich möchte mal dahin. Und irgendwann habe ich dann aber gemerkt, ob du es machst wie Buschmann oder wie Wolf Hus oder Marcel Reif oder Fritz von Turn und Taxis. Das ist nicht wichtig, sondern dass du bei dir bist. Mach das so, wie du dich wohlfühlst. Mach das so, wenn du in den Spiegel schaust nach dem Spiel. Hast du alles richtig gemacht, alles, was du dir vielleicht vorgenommen hast? Und wenn dann die Antwort ist, ja, also 95 Prozent von dem hast du durchbekommen, dann bin ich zufrieden, dann bin ich glücklich. Es gibt da kein Vorbild mehr, aber es gibt wunderbare, tolle Kollegen, zu denen ich aufschaue. Vorgestern haben wir abends dann noch nach den Sendungen zusammengestanden. Und dann war ich dann in einem Raum, Lars Stindl war der Co-Kommentator vom Deutschlandspiel, den ich von Borussia kenne, dann war da Balak, dann war da Kerner, dann war wohl Fuß und ich stand dann da. Und ich habe die ganze Zeit nichts gesagt. Das musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Ja, wenn der Kuchen spricht, dann müssen die Krümel schweigen.
Ich habe nichts gesagt und ich sauge das einfach auf. Ich sauge das einfach auf und wir haben das Glück, glaube ich, in Deutschland, auch wenn man das manchmal nicht wahrhaben will, oder es gibt viele Kritiker, es gibt viel im Netz und so, aber dass wir echt richtig tolle Journalisten haben in diesem Land, richtig tolle Sportreporter haben in diesem Land, die die Sachen echt gut machen. Und es gibt da niemanden, wo du sagst, warum kommentiert er eigentlich ein Fußballspiel, also aus meiner Warte heraus. Und da jetzt irgendwie ein kleiner Teil dabei zu sein, das ist schon ein Traum, den ich lebe.
Zwei Fragen habe ich noch, den Rest spare ich mir fürs Tribünengespräch, was wir irgendwann machen. Und da geht es dann nur um deine Karriere. Und zwar die erste Frage ist, wie verändert sich das Kommentieren, wenn du einen Experten mit dabei hast, und ist es für dich als Kommentator immer besser?
Es ist auf jeden Fall erleichternder, weil wenn ich jetzt an Martin Strandsell denke, der dann am Montag kommt, dann weiß ich, um die harten Sachen kümmert sich der ehemalige Weltklasse-Verteidiger. Wenn ich dann immer sagen kann, faul spiele und dann gucke ich rüber, dann muss er natürlich sagen, war es das oder nicht? Oder was ändert sich taktisch zum Beispiel? Ganz ehrlich, ich habe dir ja gerade schon gesagt, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich hier sitze und keine Ahnung habe, sonst würde ich wahrscheinlich kein Fußball kommentieren. Aber wenn ich das vergleiche mit Jan Henkel zum Beispiel oder anderen Analysten, habe ich keine Ahnung. Ich habe zum Beispiel ein Fußballspiel mit Manuel Baum und Jan Henkel zusammen geguckt und habe gedacht, ich habe keine Ahnung von Fußball, was die da erzählt haben. Und wenn ich dann neben mir einen habe, der Champions League gespielt hat etc., warum soll ich den Leuten zu Hause erklären, was da jetzt taktisch passiert? Das macht der mal bitte schön. Ich freue mich, weil ich es einfach viereinhalb Jahre gemacht habe mit einem Gast zusammen. Ich freue mich einfach, das Spiel irgendwie zu teilen, die Einschätzungen zu teilen. Ich freue mich vor allen Dingen ganz oft, wenn ich dann rübergebe in ein Studio und die dort, vor allen Dingen die Experten, das erzählen, was ich gerade im Kommentar auch gesagt habe, dann weiß ich natürlich, okay, wir haben das zumindest beide so gesehen. Und wenn es zwei so sehen, dann kann das ja schon mal kein Zufall gewesen sein. Ich glaube, dass das ein Mehrwert ist. Ich war immer ein Fan davon, wenn zwei das Spiel kommentieren. Das mag ich einfach. Dann gibt es ein tolles Zusammenspiel. Ich mag ja vor allen Dingen auch ein bisschen Humor dabei, weil wir ja bei dieser ganzen Ernsthaftigkeit, die der Fußball ausstrahlt. Es ist ernst. Es ist alles ernst. Mag ich es, dass wir uns auch noch mal daran zurückerinnern, dass das auch ein bisschen Unterhaltung ist. Dass wir uns ja auch auf den Platz, wenn wir irgendwo hingehen und unser Amateurverein gucken, da gehen wir auch nicht hin, um zu sagen, heute wird es ernst, sondern heute treffe ich noch XY. Da gibt es noch ein Kaltgetränk, eine Bratwurst dazu. Und dann haben wir mal Spaß. Und auf einmal übertragen wir das Ganze auf einen riesen Bildschirm. Dann ist da Euro steht da drauf oder Champions League steht da drauf. Dann macht es auf einmal keinen Spaß mehr, oder wie? Dann ist keine Unterhaltung mehr da. Och, und der Moderator, der hat ja vorher, und dann ist der Gast, warum ist der Gast Mark Forster oder whatever. Freunde, es soll ja auch ein bisschen Spaß machen, das Leben. Wahrscheinlich möchtest du hin und wieder dann da noch einen Professor, Doktor oder sowas haben.
Ne, ich will Infotainment.
Ja, Infotainment ist doch super, oder?
Genau, ich finde, Fußball ist immer ein Unterhaltungsprodukt. Und gerade beim Übertragen des Spiels am allermeisten. Ist ja klar, dass da auch, dass der Vorlauf von den meisten Spielen nicht so ist. Wobei jetzt bei Magenta muss ich da sogar rausnehmen. Also die Analysen von Jan Henkel, da hänge ich an seinen Lippen. Das ist genau das, sowas will ich aber halt die ganze Zeit haben. Und ich weiß aber, dass ich damit die Ausnahme bin. Ne, aber das Spiel ist für mich, das ist das Unterhaltungsprodukt. Und dementsprechend wird es auch präsentiert. Ich will nur eben auch einen kleinen Infotainment dabei haben, weil ich eben glaube, dass die Erfahrung habe ich halt mit dem Rasenfunk gemacht. Erst an mir selbst, weil ich früher genauso war, dass ich mit anderen Taktik-Leuten Spiele gesehen habe, und mir gedacht habe, ok, krass, ich habe ja keine Ahnung von Fußball. Das ist ja völlig verrückt. Ich gucke meinen Leben lang Fußball und ich weiß nicht, wovon ihr redet. Und jetzt bekomme ich zurückgespielt, dass es vielen Hörerinnen und Hörern auch so geht. Dass sie sagen, krass, seitdem ich den Rasenfunk höre, sehe ich auf einmal anders Fußball. Und das finde ich spannend. Und es muss ja nicht jeder zum Taktik-Fetischisten werden, aber ich glaube, manchmal müssen Dinge erklärt werden, weil es auch ehrlicherweise einfach geht.
Definitiv.
Das habt ihr ja auch super gezeigt. Der kommentierte Taktik-Stream, mit aber auch Zeitlupen dann von den entscheidenden Szenen, dass man dann, wenn man auch wirklich sehen muss, ob jetzt der Zweikampf fair oder nicht geführt wurde, dass man das dann auch sieht, ist für mich die beste Erfindung dieser EM gewesen. Das ist sehr nerdig mit Manuel Baum, auch vom Idiom her, muss man so ehrlich sagen. Ich verstehe es halt, weil ich auch Süddeutscher bin. Aber das ist einfach so gut, weil du die Möglichkeit hast, Dinge zu lernen. Und ich glaube, es ist genau dieser Mix. Die wichtigen Dinge musst du erklären. Kannst auch mal sagen, okay, gut, das ist jetzt interessant. Da hat jetzt der ein auf den anderen reagiert. Weil es wird immer so getan, als ob die Mannschaften mit einer Formation ins Spiel gehen und dann ist Halbzeit und dann stellen sie vielleicht nochmal um und dann durchwechseln, aber es verschiebt sich ja ganz oft in der ersten Halbzeit was. Und das reicht ja, wenn du einmal kurz sagst, achten sie mal drauf. Die Mitte ist jetzt, haben sie zugemacht, da lässt sich jetzt einer reinfallen. Deswegen jetzt geht alles nur rüber Flanken.
Absolut. Als Russland dann auch die Taktik gewechselt hat auf 3, 4, 3, obwohl die ganz anders angefangen haben, um Dänemark zum Beispiel zu spiegeln, dann sage ich das natürlich auch oder gebe das an die Hand oder versuche mir selber zu erklären, warum machen die das denn jetzt. Aber da ins Detail zu gehen, da hast du richtig gesagt, das dann in die Halbzeit zu packen, zu Jan Henkel. Vielleicht sowieso als Learning für die Zukunft. Also so ein Spiel, wo dann die Halbzeitanalyse daraus besteht, zu sagen, wir gehen jetzt in die Werbung, dann kommen wir wieder raus und dann gehen wir wieder in die Werbung, das befriedigt mich natürlich auch nicht. Das liegt dann aber oftmals vermutlich an teuren Rechten. Aber vielleicht ist es ja auch so, dass bald so ein Taktikfeed immer angeboten wird für eben Taktikfittischisten, wo man dann schon weiß, der erste Knopf der Hose ist schon geöffnet, wenn es gleich losgeht.
Oder so, wie man es jetzt mit Schiedsrichterexperten macht, dass man die zuschaltet, wenn es nötig ist. Das frage ich mich immer, warum man das nicht auch mit einem Jan Henke macht. Ich weiß, dass das natürlich ein Produktionsaufwand ist und sonstiges dahinterstünde. Aber das fände ich spannend. Dann muss es nämlich auch nicht so sein wie bei den prominenten Experten. Die müssen ja einmal pro Halbzeit zugeschaltet werden, sonst erinnern wir uns nicht mehr, dass Basti Schweinsteiger jetzt irgendwie der ARD-Experte ist. Und dann sagt er aber vielleicht auch etwas in der Phase des Spiels, in der sie einfach nichts getan hat. Italien spielt die zweite Halbzeit genauso wie die erste Halbzeit. Türkei schafft es immer noch nicht. Ja, okay, herzlichen Dank, mir das jetzt nochmal 40 Sekunden lang erklären zu lassen. Okay, kann man machen. Aber das fände ich irgendwie spannend, dass du sagst, wenn der Taktikexperte sagt, der meldet sich und sagt, jetzt haben wir hier was Interessantes, was sie verschoben hat, gib mir mal 30 Sekunden, der Kommentator gibt an mich ab bei der nächsten Möglichkeit, und dann sage ich das kurz, dann kann man es noch ein bisschen mehr ins Spiel reinholen. So was fände ich super. Setz das doch bitte einfach mal durch.
Hör mal, das ist ein Traum, aber ich habe dir schon mal vorhin gesagt, von den wenigen Wochen Vorbereitung, die Magenta ja hatte auf diese Europameisterschaft, und dafür, und das sage ich nicht, weil ich Teil bin, sondern weil ich natürlich auch andere Dinge lese, oder auch lese, was sagen denn die Zuschauer, das ist ja wichtig, was sagen denn unsere Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer, wie finden die das? Stell dir vor, wir hätten noch ein paar Wochen mehr, da hätte man ja noch mehr machen können, oder man nimmt das für die WM 22, was kann man dann noch umsetzen, etc. Aber ich glaube, dass wir wirklich das ein oder andere da bei Magenta TV angestoßen haben, was man vielleicht sagt, das kann man übernehmen, das macht das Fußball oder das Sportübertragen noch mal sinniger, noch mal unterhaltsamer, denn nachdem Kerner mit Ballack gesprochen hat, zu Jan Henkel schaltet, kommt Amelie Stiefvater, sitzt bei uns in der Lounge und spricht mit Gast XY dieses Spiel noch mal aus einer anderen Perspektive, die eines Sportlers, eines Künstlers, eines Fußballfans. Das komprimiert alles in einem Studio, in eine Sendung. Also ich muss nicht mal, ich hätte es mir auch so gekauft. Und hätte es da verfolgt.
Sehr guter Wachbotschafter. Aber ich gebe dir in ganz vielen Punkten Recht, muss ich wirklich sagen. Aber das bezieht sich eigentlich auf alle übertragenen Sender. Ich persönlich bin sehr zufrieden damit, wie der Fußball hier präsentiert wird, wie er auch in den Kontext dieser, nicht ganz so einfach zu verstehenen EM eingebettet wird. Also da muss ich echt sagen, das ist nicht so einfach, da über alle politischen und sonstigen Themen auch noch zu sprechen.
Mir fällt gerade ein, was ich vorhin noch sagen wollte bei den Kommentatoren. Ich habe nicht Tom Bartels genannt. Ich möchte aber explizit Tom Bartels nennen, weil er ja auch das Spiel kommentiert hat wie ich, Dänemark-Russland, und ich habe das natürlich auch danach wahrgenommen. Ich habe das Spiel nicht gesehen, aber die Kritik, ich habe gesehen, dass ein Social-Media-Mensch von der ARD sich entschuldigt hat. Nicht die ARD hat sich entschuldigt oder sowas, sondern da stecken ein, zwei Social-Media-Leute dahinter, die nur jemandem geantwortet haben. Da wurde, glaube ich, mehr daraus gemacht, als es ist. Aber Tom Bartels hat danach ja so ein tolles Zitat gegeben, wenn sich von dieser ganzen Gemengelage da 25.000, das Spiel an sich, die Vorgeschichte mit Ericsson, da nicht elektrisieren lässt und dann auch emotional ist, der sollte sich einen anderen Beruf suchen. Ich glaube, ich habe das gefeiert, als ich das gelesen habe. Du bist natürlich neutral als Kommentator, das ist klar. Ich war auch neutral, trotzdem habe ich mich irgendwann von den Dänen natürlich auch einnehmen lassen. Aber ich hätte mich auch von den Russen einnehmen lassen. Das ist einfach so. Man hat ja sehr oft, dass man nach irgendwas, was da passiert ist, mit dem Finger auf jemanden zeigt. Warum hast du das nicht? Hättest du das nicht? Weil die selber die Situation gar nicht kennen, in der man dann ist. Da fand ich echt, was Kritik angeht, an den, nicht nur Menschen, sondern Kommentator Tom Bartels, wirklich in Gesamtheit. Es gibt ja viele, die ihn grundsätzlich in Frage gestellt haben. Da hab ich gedacht, seid ihr völlig durchgedreht oder was?
Dieses Pauschal ist natürlich totaler Quatsch. Es ist halt was Emotionales. Es ist wie, wenn du mit Leuten über Musik diskutierst oder über Kunst im Generellen. Dadurch, dass der Bemärtungsmaßstab ein subjektiver ist, ist es schwierig, dazu was zu sagen. Allein darüber könnte ich jetzt sehr lange mit dir diskutieren. Ich habe auch einen kritischen Tweet abgesetzt, habe ihn allerdings am nächsten Tag gelöscht, weil ich mir gedacht habe, ich möchte eigentlich gar nicht der Typ sein, der jetzt auch zu so einer negativen Stimmung beiträgt. Ich hoffe allerdings, dass er differenzierter war als vielleicht zu manchen Kritik, die du gerade gemeint hast. Ich habe noch eine letzte Frage. Und zwar, warum gibt es immer noch so wenige Kommentatorinnen?
Boah, wenn ich das wüsste. Ich kenne zum Beispiel eine, also leider nicht persönlich, aber wir haben schriftlichen Kontakt, sagt man das so. Ich fühle mich mit 32 gerade wie so ein alter Opfer. Wir schreiben übers Netz, über Social Media, über Twitter, über Instagram. Stefanie Baschik, die in der ARD ist, kann man das so sagen. Sie macht, glaube ich, auch für Radio Berlin Brandenburg unterwegs. Sie macht jetzt die Europameisterschaft. Die haben ja jetzt auch mittlerweile einen digitalen Kanal. Sie übernehmen daher auch die Bundesliga-Rechte ab jetzt der Saison, die die Amazon hatte. Und ich habe sie zufällig mal vor ein paar Monaten gehört, weil ich das erste Mal seit langem mal wieder Sportschau geguckt habe. Hab gedacht, meine Güte, wie toll ist das denn? Das hört sich richtig geil an. Und das habe ich ihr dann geschrieben. Also geil habe ich jetzt nicht verwendet. Das war jetzt mein jugendlicher Leichtsinn, der hier gerade durchgegangen ist. Sondern es hört sich einfach richtig toll an. Für mich, für meine Ohren ist es brutal gut. Das habe ich ihr geschrieben und haben uns ein bisschen ausgetauscht. Und das verfolge ich zum Beispiel. Und weiß, die wird irgendwann mal in der ARD ein Spiel live kommentieren. Deutschland gegen was auch immer, weil die einfach richtig gut ist. Und ich glaube, dass mittlerweile auf dem Markt, da kommen ja immer mehr. Immer mehr, immer mehr. Es geht ja auch gar nicht, glaube ich, darum, bist du ein Mann, bist du eine Frau, sondern bist du gut oder bist du ihm nicht gut. Kannst du das oder nicht? Bringst du irgendwas mit?
Ich bin mir da immer noch nicht so ganz sicher. Aber es sind also so viele mehr als Steffi. Wir sind eh alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer, weil sie auch manchmal hier im Rasenfunk mit dabei ist, finde ich auch ganz toll. Aber so viele neue Namen gibt es eben gar nicht. Mir fallen jetzt gar nicht so viele ein und ich halte immer Ausschau.
Ich frage mich ja auch, reden wir, reden wir da, natürlich es gibt mittlerweile ja so viele Diskussionen, aber vielleicht gibt es auch aktuell gar nicht so viele, die das werten wollen, sondern die wollen lieber vor der Kamera stehen, die wollen lieber Interviews führen, die wollen vielleicht gar nicht 90 Minuten Fußballspiel kommentieren. Ich zum Beispiel persönlich kenne niemanden. Ich habe noch nie eine in dieser Branche kennengelernt, die zu mir gesagt hat, ich will Fußball kommentieren. Dafür habe ich aber schon acht Millionen Menschen getroffen, also Männer getroffen, die das gesagt haben.
Ja gut, aber das sind natürlich auch die guten alten Rollenbilder. Also du kommst auch solange du etwas nicht siehst, kommst auch nicht auf den Gedanken, es selber machen zu können.
Das heißt, es fehlt so ein Role-Model. Aber Claudia Neumann mittlerweile ist doch auch, die hat doch auch schon alles gemacht im ZDF.
Aber es ist quasi immer noch so, dass dir auffällt, wenn eine Frau Fußball kommentiert. Also würde ich jetzt einfach mal so unterstellen. Und ich glaube, wenn es irgendwann so ist, dass es halt völlig normal ist, dass es mal eine weibliche Stimme ist, mal eine männliche Stimme, dann wird das auch eher so. Also zumindest geht dahin die Forschung in dem Bereich des Weites. Das heißt ja, in vielen Bereichen des Lebens geht es jetzt nicht nur um Fußball kommentieren. Aber das hat mich eben nur interessiert. Und ich würde dir aber auch da zustimmen. Also es tut sich ein bisschen was, aber so immer noch so granular. Ich hoffe, dass da irgendwann eine Entwicklung kommt, was ich aber sehr positiv finde, ist die Einbindung von Frauen in Fußballübertragung. Im Gesamtkontext hat sich krass verändert. Also du hast Almut Schollt bei der ARD sitzen. Du hast Ariane Hingst als Expertin. Du hast Martina Vosteklenburg. Die sind bei dem ZDF zusammen natürlich mit Claudia Neumann. Du hast eben Steffi Bartik, die zu hören ist bei euch. Amelie Stiefvater, auch wenn sie da jetzt den bunten Teil in Anführungszeichen macht. Aber es gibt jetzt eine andere Präsenz von Frauen im Fußball.
Wir haben noch Annette Sattler, die ist im Deutschen Quartier. Auch wunderbare Kolleginnen vor und hinter der Kamera. Ich glaube, dass das jetzt so langsam kommt, weil die Mädchen, die jetzt noch jünger sind und dann auch den Traum haben, jetzt vielleicht noch mutiger dadurch sind, dass sie sagen, wir können das jetzt auch mal versuchen, weil wir sehen, es funktioniert auch, es wird auch angenommen. Da sind auch Frauen. Ich glaube, dass die echt viel mitmachen müssen, wenn wir an die sozialen Netzwerke gehen und so was. Einfach nur, weil du eine Frau bist. Ich habe über so viele Themen, ich habe ganz tolle Freundinnen, mit denen ich über alles sprechen kann. Da geht es ja auch um Sachen wie eine Frau, die geboren wird, muss schon Dinge wie die Pille zum Beispiel oder Verhütungsmittel per se, wird ja immer auf die Frau auch oft geschoben. Das sollst du immer machen. Kosmetikartikel und so. Das müssen die alles kaufen. Das kriegen die gar nicht geschenkt. Das sind Gelder, die müssen wir gar nicht ausgeben.
Verstehst du? Ja, das berühmte Friseur-Beispiel. Wir zwei gehen zum Friseur, zahlen keine Ahnung, je nachdem, welche Güteklasse, irgendwas zwischen 10 und 40 Euro. Und Frau geht zum Friseur, hat vielleicht auch eine kurze Frisurzeit, auf jeden Fall 70 bis 100.
Diese ganzen Sachen, da wird sich sowas, aber ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind gerade mittendrin. Da wird sich so viel tun, weil ich habe auch tolle Kolleginnen zum Beispiel. Eine meiner besten Freundinnen, Christina, die auch bei uns arbeitet, die kann so viel, die ist so toll und die geht aus sich raus. Aber manchmal hatte ich das Gefühl in der Vergangenheit, vor allen Dingen im Fußball-Business, da musst du noch mal ein bisschen anders sein, da musst du noch mal ein bisschen mehr kämpfen als alle anderen, obwohl du schon sofort mehr, die kann mehr als ich, die kann viel mehr als ich. Aber bei ihr hätte das ein bisschen länger gedauert. Ich glaube, in ein paar Jahren ist das vorbei, weil es so Menschen gibt, wie du und ich, sagen wir mal, die erkennen das nicht, die sagen nicht, aber warum muss das denn so? Das muss doch ein Mann machen, das muss doch eine Frau machen. Das ist einfach weg irgendwann, das soll einfach alles weg sein. Genauso wie, wenn wir jetzt über Regenbogenfahnen sprechen und so was. Diese ganzen Menschen, die da irgendwas dagegen haben, aus irgendwelchen geistesgestörten Gründen, die werden sich irgendwann hoffentlich verziehen, in ihrer Ecke sollen die einen Scheißdreck labern, wir sind offen, wir sind bereit, Frau und Mann ist gleich, lieb, wen du willst. Es ist alles völlig wurscht, wir sind eine Welt, lass uns gemeinsam tolle Sachen erleben, gemeinsam fröhlich sein, jetzt kommt die Sonne raus und so was. Ich will diesen ganzen Hass, diese ganzen Diskriminierungs-Sachen, diese ganze Unterdrückung und was weiß ich, die will ich irgendwann nicht mehr hören. Die werden wir irgendwann zerstören, sage ich einfach mal.
Oh Gott, ich wünsche mir, ich hätte da einen positiven Vibe. Christian, das hat sehr großen Spaß gemacht, wir könnten noch eine Stunde weitermachen, aber an der Stelle, wenn du es schon ansprichst, wenn euch das Thema interessiert, Frauen und ihre Stellung in der Welt. Ich habe gerade im Hotel Matze Margerite Stokowski gehört, fand ich sehr, sehr gut. Also Podcast-Empfehlung an dieser Stelle. Christian, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du hier warst. Man kann dir auf Twitter folgen als atc-stra und man kann dir auf Instagram folgen als christian-straßburger Ihr seid alle herzlich eingeladen, mir da in die DMs zu sliden. Da hast du jetzt das Tor geöffnet. Danke dir, dass du hier warst im Rasenfunk.
Danke schön, habe die Ehre.
Und euch herzlichen Dank liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer für eure Aufmerksamkeit der Rasenfunk. Er bleibt werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir sind allein Hörerinnen und Hörer finanziert. Das heißt, unterstützt uns bitte auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Erfahrt ihr, wie ihr das tun könnt. Und ansonsten hören wir uns wieder am nächsten Jahr im Spieltag. So wie ihr das kennt hier im Kurzpass und nach dem nächsten Deutschlandspiel in der Schlusskonferenz. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund und passt auf euch auf.